Jetzt geht es richtig los ausgerechnet europa wird die erste hyper look strecke in den künftigen ausmaßen gebaut
Also in originalgröße und so die sie dann, mal
Im regelbetrieb funktionieren soll das ganze passiert in frankreich in toulouse dort hat das unternehmen hyper lufti
Ein forschungszentrum eröffnet und fängt jetzt mit dem bau der strecke an alles über den größten fortschritt des hyper lobs
Jetzt index, um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Es ist soweit und ich bekomme ein bisschen gänsehaut der heime look startet und das ausgerechnet in europa was beim
transrapid von den ersten planungen bis zur ersten teststrecke jahrzehnte gedauert hat das geht hier wirklich in windeseile vonstatten und dazu war der
transrapid eine einzige fehlplanung 2002 wurde die erste
Kommerzielle strecke in china eingeweiht aber zu laut zu hässlich und er verbraucht zu viel strom die folgen er verkehrt nur mit wenigen passagieren
Fährt 0 so schnell wie ein ic weil der strom sonst zu teuer wäre und er wird nicht weiter gebaut und das bei einer
So vielversprechenden technologien der hypo nun scheint die nachteile
Des transrapid zu vermeiden die idee ist auch viel einfacher und ziemlich genial und solche ideen machen auf den unterschied aus
Manchmal ist es wirklich papieren dabei ist die idee für den hyper look wirklich super einfach rohrpost und die könnte der
magnetschwebetechnik jetzt im nachhinein zum erfolg verhelfen das prinzip der zug oder beim heimklub eine kapsel wird in eine röhre
gepackt und in der herrscht ein vakuum
bzw ist kaum noch luft enthalten ein sogenanntes teil vakuum
hochleistungspumpen pumpen die luft aus der röhre und erhalten das vakuum der effekt es gibt kein
luftwiderstand mehr das hauptproblem und der energiefresser
Jedes schnellen transport mittels er ist einfach weg damit brauche ich für den zug kaum noch energie ist der einmal beschleunigte sollen
Solarzellen auf den transporteuren ausreichen um für die energie, zu sorgen mit rund 1200 kilometern pro stunde soll er zwischen
metropolen verkehr schneller als mit einem flugzeug und eine neue
magnetschwebetechnik ist geplant weil der deutlich weniger energie verbraucht wird
Permanentmagneten die im sogenannten
holborn
angeordnet sind sollen zum einen die magnetkraft in die kapsel nahezu auf null
Reduzieren und im gegenzug unten zum transport track verstärken in dem track heißt die technik die von hyper lob
transporttaschen technologies angewendet wird und ihre
teststrecke für diese technologie wird jetzt eben gebaut erst mal nicht besonders sagen dann als 20 meter die röhren haben einen durchmesser von vier metern
und sind damit für güter und auch schon für den personentransport
Geeignet die ersten röhren fertig und werden bereits an ihren
Bestimmungsort gebracht dieses jahr noch soll die tests gefertigt werden und im sommer schon das erste
testfahrzeug das würden auch in europa in einem werk in spanien gefertigt und im nächsten jahr
Würde es dann richtig amtlich dann wird eine ein kilometer
lange teststrecke gebaut wird karbon ceo von hyper lucchetti dazu bei haifa
Not geht es um mehr als schnelle beschleunigung unserer sprechen von
Geschwindigkeitsrekorden es ist eine echte chance ein effizientes und sicheres system
Mit einem einzigartigen erlebnis für die reisenden zu erschaffen und das ganze geht natürlich mal wieder man. Muss sagen
natürlich
Selbstverständlich auch wem zurück auf ihnen maske er hatte die bahnbrechende idee aber gab
sie frei jeder darf entwickeln und bauen macht hält sich vollkommen raus und besucher vielleicht mal die verschiedenen
Standorte der konkurrenten denn auch virgin chef richard branson ist mal wieder mit
Am start er hat das zweite unternehmen das am heimflug dran es gekauft
ausflug wurde virgin
es bleibt also
Extrem spannend wenn er als erstes neues zum thema hyper lob und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer hierbei whatsapp
Dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video täglich garantieren kriegt auch meldungen außer der reihe und zur begrüßung
Gibt es noch ein kleines geschenk einfach hier draufklicken und topaktuell dabei sein und natürlich nicht das abo mit der
Genau glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken hyper luke deutsche strecke geplant ansonsten bis dann
bleib dran